there's a lot of critics of the bitcoin
and cryptocurrency technologies that for
years have been bragging about the fact
that they believed the u.s government
was going to ban outlaw or prevent the
adoption of these technologies well my
friends every single one of those
critics was wrong the u.s government and
the current administration behind
president biden has come forward this
morning and they've put an executive
order out that executive order
specifically focuses on ensuring
responsible innovation in digital assets
that's right the us government is not
going to ban bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies it's not going to ban
the use of blockchain technology it's
the exact opposite the u.s government
understands that this is of strategic
importance it is going to embrace this
technology it is going to try to become
the leader of bitcoin crypto and
blockchain technology now of course as
you dig in to what's actually in the
executive order it only gets more
bullish from there we've got seven
different points that they're focused on
in this executive order the first is to
protect u.s consumers investors and
businesses the second is to protect the
u.s and global financial stability and
mitigate systemic risk the third is to
mitigate illicit finance and national
security risks posed by the illicit use
of digital assets the fourth is to
promote u.s leadership and technology
and economic competitiveness to
reinforce u.s leadership in the global
financial system the fifth is to promote
equitable access to safe and affordable
financial services the sixth is to
support technological advances and
ensure responsible development and use
of digital assets and lastly to explore
a u.s central bank digital currency now
of course every single one of those
critics every single one of the bears
everyone who was touting that the us
government was going to ban these
technologies not only are they wrong but
they were really really misplaced in
their fear-mongering because the u.s
government understands that this
technology not only creates safer and
fairer markets but it's absolutely
essential for many of the communities
that are the most marginalized or
misplaced in our society ultimately
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies are good
for business they're good for
individuals they're good for
corporations they're good for financial
institutions and now we're seeing the
united states publicly state bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies are good for nation
states too this executive order has
validated this industry in less than 15
years we've gone from inception to about
three trillion dollars in market cap and
now we have the largest nation states in
the world coming out and saying we want
to be a leader we have to embrace this
technology the future is bright my
friends we're just getting started hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time